ich spiele gerade nichts das geht nicht
ich kann das nicht machen und herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einem erneuten video mit dem
ein trecker nachdem meine reaction auf
katja vor einigen tagen über 84.000
daumen hoch bekommen hat und auch eine
altersbeschränkung leider da haben wir
ganz ganz viele leute geschrieben ich
sollte mich auch mal an der challenge
probieren die beispielsweise aus die man
vor einigen tagen gemacht hatte und auch
viele andere youtuber sich daran schon
die zähne ausgebissen haben
challenge ich habe jetzt schon ziemlich
angst ich hab mit drei videos
rausgesucht die wir uns heute zusammen
anschauen werden
acht alpakas
das erste video ist ein video mit
spinnen und nicht mit normalen kleinen
spinnen die gegen die rumlaufen
das ist das sind wirklich schon recht
große ossis da ich würde sagen ich
leider gar nicht lange drumherum
ich muss die ganze zeit auf diese spinne
schauen und wir blicken jetzt einfach
mal auf play
alter
[Musik]
das nicht
ich gehe
ich kann mit ständig anschauen vor allem
entspinnen dann so rum chillen und
einfach nichts machen alter denke ich
die springt jeden moment irgendwie in
die kamera zu alter der die sieht aus
wie ein skorpion
ich kann ich kann das nicht warum mache
ich denn so dumme videos immer okay
lukas
[Musik]
ich wusste es dass sie auf die kamera zu
bringen ich habe sogar vorher gesagt hey
leute ich nehme seit sechs minuten auf
und ich habe schon ein halbes
herzinfarkt weitergeht hier freunde
keine müdigkeit vortäuschen ich muss
mich schon okay ich schaue da wirklich
hin ich weiß nicht ist das nun wirklich
eine spinne oder ok
seine komplette rad
baden war die schau dich an ich schaue
dich an hey einheit reka checks dass ich
schuldig bin ich schaue sie auch es geht
nicht es geht nicht es geht nicht
guckt sie euch an
also
es geht nicht
es geht nicht ich kann es sich ich kann
das nicht ich kann es wirklich nicht ich
habe wirklich eine panische angst vor
spinnen
es geht nicht ich kann nicht mal spinnen
töten ich kann nicht dass leute dass es
gerade noch schnitt mit eines der
schwierigsten videos die ich je
aufgenommen habe alter was kommt die so
nah ist nicht schrecken ich gucke nicht
ok ich muss schon es geht nicht um mein
gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
nein es geht nicht leute wirklich
das geht nicht
ich kann das nicht wirklich nötig ich
spiele gerade nichts das geht nicht ich
kann das nicht machen das video geht
noch eine minute alltag bekommen luca
ich muss mich einfach anstrengend ich
muss mich anstrenge sind einfach nur
noch das sind einfach nur ganz normale
er ist ein ganz normaler tag an ganz
normale tiere gott oh mein gott was
jedoch nicht an die schau in safe schaut
wirklich in diesen trecker funktionieren
man hinschaut safe wirklich auf diese
spinne wirklich leute glaubt mir
bist du wahnsinnig ist total gesperrt
du kannst die maus große pause drücken
s
ich bin
ich stehe ganz schön alltag
luca du hast drei videos draußen so dass
hier ist das erste video ich habe noch
zwei andere videos gesucht einmaleins
mit glaube ich unfällen oder so und noch
einmal eins mit höhenangst um leute am
klettern sind noch irgendwelchen
hochhäusern oder so was sicher auch
schlimm finde ich schaue er hin
safe leute die schau in diese ein
und das ist was ich gesehen habe
ok fazit erstes video spinnen
ich habe komplett verschließen was
danach trinken weil ich also für über
den schweiß kraft verloren haben wir
allerdings nun zum zweiten video hier
der 80
das habe ich schon mal gesehen ach du
grüne neune achtteilige reihe ersetzt
andere gehen ins restaurant verdi gehen
auf den kran
ich habe glaube ich den sinn dieser
trend nicht ganz verstanden ich muss die
ganze zeit hinschauen luca drückte ich
schaue einfach mit deinen augen auf den
scheiß monitor
krass krass wie kann man so lebensmittel
sein alter das ist wahnsinn
oh mein gott kein scheiß leute ich hab
richtig höhenangst oh mein gott walther
der ist auf einem skateboard und fährt
auf den an den rand dazu und schaut als
runter diesen tätigen kenne ich auch
schon den kämpfer schon auf einigen
anderen videos macht das relativ häufig
in schönau vom fernsehturm oder so er
hier den ich dachte er springt komplett
runter
oh mein gott dass die dann auch nicht
einfach nur chillen können sondern sie
müssen dann ja auch noch mal runter
schauen
du bist echt lebensmitteln also das ist
wirklich unnormal krass ich finde solche
videos klar auf der einen seite halt
atemberaubend und beeindruckend solche
perspektiven zu sehen aber auf der
anderen seite wirklich
die sich einfach auf den flügel gelegt
kein geld für ein flugticket hast leute
ich glaube ich bin bisher in diesem
video 50 jahre gealtert apropos gealtert
ich hatte ja gestern geburtstag und
wollte mich an der stelle auch noch mal
ganz ganz ganz ganz toll bei euch
bedanken für die ganzen glückwünsche
jetzt 3 pp die einerseits unter das
gestrige video geschrieben wurden
andererseits aber auch auf instagram und
die ganzen platz videos und so gestern
in meinem geburtstag ist ja dieser rudi
im luca shop gelauncht und der war
instant komplett ausverkauft also danke
für euren kranken supports jeglicher art
und weise
und wenn ihr mir noch ein
geburtstagsgeschenk machen wollt dann
nutzt gerne luca als support create a
cot report mainz dadurch bekommt ihr
keine mehrkosten also wenn ihr euch was
kauf kostet es nicht nichts mehr aber
das quasi von dem geld was ein epic
games geht bekomme ich ein bisschen was
ab die tage kommt auf jeden fall auch
wieder antworten das video aber wir
gehen jetzt auf das dritte video was ich
ausgesucht habe hopping giant samples
don't look challenge also was ich mir
hierfür sachen ausgesucht haben das ist
echt so ein großer haufen scheiße hier
geht es darum dass
also ist ja nur menschlich das ist ja
jetzt nicht irgendwie wie ein krasser
unfall und jemand fehlt doch die fresse
und überall ist blut und keine ahnung
was sondern es ist ja einfach nur pickel
die ausgedrückt werden
dennoch ist ekelhaft war das ist ja
abartig was hat er irgendwas haben oh
mein gott
ich musste es gar zensieren für euch es
ist einfach nur eine pinke pinke es ist
einfach nur ein ganz normaler pickel
aber da ist halt ein bisschen blut und
da das katja video auch schon aus
heiterem himmel gesperrt wurde von
youtube also zumindest am 18 was wurde
will ich gerade kein risiko eingehen
wow das ist echt ekelhaft sorry das kann
ich mir nicht anschauen
das kann ich mir nicht anschauen ganz im
ernst ich will euch das nicht zumuten
auf der zuschauerseite und ich will es
mir auch gerade nicht zumuten weil ich
bin ganz ehrlich ich habe ein richtig
mulmiges gefühl seit dem spinnen video
wenn ich daran denke wie schütz sieht
man dass ich weiß nicht ob man das hier
sehen kann aber meine haare auf dem arm
die haben sich komplett also wirklich
komplett hochgestellt an der stelle
durch das video jetzt auf jeden fall
auch beenden wir lieben freunde diese
download the way challenge ich würde
gerne sagen hat mir echt spaß gemacht
aber hat halt leider überhaupt nicht
wenn euch das video hier auf jeden fall
gefallen hat dann würde ich mich sehr
sehr sehr sehr dollar bei einem daumen
hoch freuen meine damen und herren das
war für mich echt eine überwindung
dieses video aufzunehmen soll ich
eventuell noch mal ein video mit dem
trecker machen dann schreibt mir eine
idee damit dafür unten in die kommentare
reichen nicht auch mal irgendein spiel
damit spielen oder auf ein anderes video
reagieren nur was ihr möchtet
schreibstil gerne und in die kommentare
wie bereits gesagt nutzt gerne luca als
support creator code bei vor neid das
würde mich sehr freuen
die tage kommt auch ein neues fortnight
video und jetzt
[Musik]